I'm Philip a sharp Institute professor
at MIT in the Koch Institute for
Integrative Cancer Research I want to
talk about RNA splicing and the
discovery of split genes but I want to
set it in the context of the question of
what is a gene because we use the word
gene when we talk to each other but when
we start thinking about it in the
context of specific biochemical
structure the genes are very complicated
and we really find it very difficult to
define a gene and this can be quite
important in terms of understanding
biology many years ago and I began in
molecular and cell biology the gene was
really quite simple and it's illustrated
here by a diagram from Jacobi minoo
which was published in 1961 illustrating
the lac operon and the Nate the
structure of the genes and the lac
operon and the messenger RNA that comes
from those genes and then the proteins
you see at the bottom of this
illustration of galactosidase permeate
and others that are encoded by that
messenger RNA and in 1961 this explained
what a gene was a gene was like Z in
that diagram a linear sequence encoding
and transferring information into an RNA
in a linear fashion and in a protein
being coded from it and we even
understood in this year 1961 that there
were sequences nearby operands that were
sis to the gene that were critical for
the expression of a gene so in the early
our late 60s early 70s when I entered
cell biology everyone suspected that
they understood a gene to the point that
mono actually made the statement but
what is true of bacteria is true of an
elephant well by and large that is the
case but in elephants a little bit more
complex than bacteria as we will see
cell biologists have long suspected even
in the early 70s that genes in
the maeín cells were somewhat more
complicated maybe there were mysteries
here and this influenced my own thinking
as I moved to coast bring harbor to
begin to study animal viruses and some
of the hints that there might be a
difference in the genetic structure in
the maeín cells or cells with nuclei was
the two general facts what is if you
look at the nucleus of a cell you see
the album's about line of the nucleus
this is the nucleus we knew that in the
nucleus of them there maeín cell there
was a thousand fold higher levels of of
DNA it was a thousandfold more complex
than in bacteria but it didn't seem that
mammalian cells would need a
thousandfold more genes so we had a lot
more DNA in the nucleus cell and we
suspected we needed four genes and then
another issue is that when we
metabolically labeled RNA in the nucleus
of a cell it was much larger than the
RNA that we found in the cytoplasm of
the cell and there was this autonomy it
was larger by a factor of five than the
size of the message in the cytoplasm so
there was this paradox long nuclear RNA
smaller cytoplasmic RNA the long nuclear
RNA had a cap at the fiber in the end
and we'll talk a little bit format that
the moment had poly a at the 3-prime in
yet it was longer and the message had
the same modifications and it was
shorter so in 1971 I moved to coast
being Harvard to start learning how to
work with atom with animal viruses and
particularly animal bars as DNA viruses
that cause cancer in animals and one of
the viruses that we worked with was Edna
Mars
- as this is a micrograph of Edna virus
- it's got a beautiful virus with capsid
proteins primarily of the heck's on
protein to constitute most of this
capsid it has its fibers at the end that
you see here that are to attach to cells
it's long enough as a genome to have 35
genes encoded
so it was a wonderful virus to work with
the probe to cell biology of cells as
well as to study the its ability to
cause cancer in animals so we started in
1970 at Cold Spring Harbor determining
the structure of the genome of Edna
virus and that led us to the development
of restriction in the nucleus Maps and
this was these are two examples of
restriction endonuclease an apple of the
adenovirus genome
what is the eco r1 here at the top and
the other is a Hindi three at the bottom
so we mapped the cleavage sites of these
restriction enzymes across the genome
and therefore were able to start
preparing a map of the relationship of
RNA two genes to the genome structure
and I want you to recall two restriction
fragments one is this Hindi 3 fragment a
fragment here and another is this eco r1
fragment right there and this hex on
messenger RNA we knew that the messenger
RNA mapped across the genome in this
position and we wanted to compare the
structure of the messenger RNA for this
hex own hex on protein to the nuclear
RNA that was expressed in the nucleus of
a cell and we were going to do this by
electron microscopy which I had learned
that Cold Spring Harbor would not coming
at caltech when I was a postdoc with
Norman Davison so when we did that and
we in this cases Suber bit in Claremore
suah postdoc Claire a technician in lab
and we did an R loop mapping between da
the messenger RNA for hex on and the
genome what we observed is shown in
these series of diagrams what is shown
all the way over here to the right is
the Hindi 3 a fragment in total and then
this is a blow-up of the piece of that R
loop and what you see here is this
section of the electron micrograph is
the rna-dna hybrid and what was puzzling
to us was here a little tail at the 3
prime end
message and what was really puzzling was
this little tail at the 5-prime end of
the message now the three prime end tato
we understood that was the poly a tract
but there shouldn't have been a tail at
the five prime end of the message it
should have annealed to the DNA
sequences and we spent a large amount of
time trying to do controls to show that
that tail really didn't come from the
DNA sequences and therefore that led us
to the question of well where did these
sequences come from and I ask you to
remember the eco r1 pregnant because
that allowed us to do a very direct
experiment to test whether the upstream
sequences are in the end the virus
genome had the sequences to this tail
and what we observed when they made the
rna-dna hybrid between the long pregnant
and the message for the hex on is
illustrated here this shows you a
diagram of it here this is the actual
micrographs there and what is striking
about this micrograph if you look in
this region is there are three loops and
that immediately told us that that tail
had sequences from three different
regions of the adenovirus genome and we
show it here in the diagram of a loop b
loop and C loop and that told us that
the RNA for this hex on message was
actually being joined together out of
four segments and it's diagrammed here
in this diagram of the rna-dna hybrid
you see the hex on RNA message and that
was the end of that electron micrograph
you see the C loop the B loop and the a
loop being created by the annealing of
these sequences off in the genome here a
B and C prime to the hex on message down
here and that immediately told us that
this RNA for the hex on message was
actually coming from a long RNA that was
being transcribed from a B and C all the
way through the genome and then spliced
together to make these three segments to
the body of the message so that told us
that
secret between the long nuclear RNA and
the shorter cytoplasmic RNA was this
process of RNA splicing the removal of
sequences from the middle of the
messenger RNA a suggestion no one had
made before and it told us more
generally that all the genes are most of
the genes in these complex mammalian
cells are expressed by this process of
RNA splicing so instant e-7 when this
work was announced and published we
created this diagram that illustrates in
the same way that Jacobi Minoo did the
flow of information from DNA into the
messenger RNA but in this case in
mammalian cells as contrasted to
bacterial cells and what you see here
then is a promoter where the RNA is
initiated the cap is synthesized and
from the work of Aaron Schock and Bernie
boss we knew a great deal about the chem
chemistry of the cap and then over here
where there was poly Abe cleavage
cutting of the RNA and a poly a site and
the poly a added making a precursor RNA
that then is spliced before the RNA is
transported to the cytoplasm here so we
diagram then the flow of information
from DNA into messenger RNA in mammalian
cells now this diagram is a little
simplified because most messenger most
genes in mammalian cells have 10
different introns not just one and
therefore there's much more splicing and
in many cases that splicing is nascent
why the RNA is being synthesized from
the DNA doesn't occur in a poly
generated precursor but in about one in
ten cases one in ten introns it is
removed post transcriptionally with this
poly a and ventilated precursor RNA so
we outlined the pathway of the synthesis
of messenger RNA and higher cells and we
knew those cells had a much more complex
structure now just for completeness and
because no one else is interested in and
no virus anymore
just let me illustrate the complexity by
which a virus uses this process of RNA
splicing to express itself you see where
as we said before there are three
different leaders exons a B and C we saw
in the previous diagram and those are
spliced to all of these messenger RNAs
across the genome so there's a long RNA
made from the left end of the genome
across the genome and all of these sets
of RNAs are processed from it and for
example this is a poly tin elation site
where the hex on message is actually
produced by splicing and this is a
another polyadenylation spite where
another major messenger RNA is used each
of these involves a long precursor
across the whole genome alternative
polyadenylation at different sites the
splicing of those 3 leaders to the end
of the message but when we look at the
other transcriptional units in the virus
here's one it's the e for e 3 e 2 and e
1 on the left side over here you see
again very complex splicing of
alternative polyadenylation and
alternative splicing accounting for the
complexity of the message from this
adenovirus genome this has led us to
think about what is actually a gene and
when you start thinking about a gene
then you ask yourself what's the unit of
information in a gene that actually
accounts for the functional unit of a
gene so this is my favorite gene this is
from Larry Sabarsky who's it UCLA
it's the dascomb gene it's expressed in
the nervous system of drosophila and it
produces 38,000 different proteins from
one gene now each of these little bars
here this is a genomic DNA diagram each
of these little bars here isn't is it
exon and what you note here is that
there are something like 33 different
exons and you can alternatively splice
one of these in each precursor messenger
RNA and this is sportier
different exons for Exxon 6 and 12 for
Exxon 4 and these are all used in
permutation producing 38,000 different
messenger rna's and different proteins
so when we talk about this gene is it
one of those exons being spliced to
another to make one functional unit that
goes into the protein or is it the whole
transcriptional unit and all 38,000
different proteins different functions
within a gene and each of those exons
could potentially be a gene so this
leads us to the question that the
cellular environment can modify the
nature of the messenger RNA in the
transfer of information from DNA to
protein in one cell the DNA sequence is
interpreted one way in another cell it's
interpreted another way so alternative
splicing and alternative polyadenylation
and something I haven't spoken about RNA
editing so a given genomic sequence is
actually not a faithful representation
of the functional information expressed
from a gene and therefore as we looked
at our genome and now we have the genome
sequence it was published in 2003 50
years after Watson and Crick and we say
to each other we have 23,000 genes well
we do have 23,000 transcription units
which for example accounts for where the
transcription begins on the left side of
this diagram and moves to the right
but you see alternative promoters
alternative poly ventilation sites
alternative splicing in the middle of
the gene here and you see in some cells
you would use this information in the
gene and in other cells by alternative
splicing you would skip that information
so what's a gene it's a it's a very
difficult question to answer when we get
to the level of my chemistry or looking
at functional units in a genetic
transmission sort of thing
we use the term gene among ourselves all
the time but when we start
specifically probing a gene the gene is
actually a very difficult thing to
define so I want to thank you for your
attention and listening to this
discussion of what is a gene